I want a pen you got a pen huh yeah
here's a pen right here
doodle you're gonna doodle I see your
Doodles though I doodle every now and
then sure why not do it with the best of
them buddy yeah I got an art degree
remember that time you and I were
swimming in the ocean
by the way we've talked about this we're
like there's shark fins out there and
the two of us are saying or I I remember
saying it's not it's not a big deal
there's a shark those are those are uh
whatever sharks they're like nothing
sharks yeah yeah they're harmless yeah
they were not they were great whites
next summer I come out I'm like oh
there's all these great whites yeah they
were great whites
and you and I are just two heads we're
bobbing in the ocean two heads and a
giant shark fin goes by it was
definitely and it was maybe eight feet
from both of us
and and both of us I don't know why both
of us both of us we weren't high or
anything both of us were looking at it
saying uh that's a shark yeah that's
what that is it's a shark yeah and I was
like yeah don't worry about it it's easy
piece of cake it's not interested in us
and then some woman got bit right off
the right there the next summer or
something like that yeah she got bit in
the foot I think yeah yeah yeah well it
happens I don't fear uh a wild animal I
just don't I don't have that in me I
would like to uh I just don't first of
all I don't first of all I don't I show
it throw out a wild animal at me and
I'll fight it I don't care what I think
everybody already knows what how often
you coming in contact with a wild animal
when's the last time just looking them
up online counts just looking him up
online count how about looking at
footage of a zoo I look at footage of
the San Diego Zoo all the time yeah yeah
um I have been uh I'm just trying to
think I've been out of my mountain bike
and I've seen some Critters you know
nothing that big keep going but uh I'll
give you some room I'm not gonna cut you
off on this one okay
um I've been I've been in the area of a
bear
meaning I think I've been in the same
state as a bear oh really yeah I like
the
dumping some stuff off I was throwing
away an RCA television from the 70s at a
dump and there was a seven eight Bears
there was very small black bears right
over there they look down they actually
look like cats now that I think of it
right everybody working there is like
check out O'Brien not worried at all you
know all kidding aside that if got
real you know that I would be a
physically Brave person
you know that you know that if the
went down you know that okay Conan Plays
the Fool oh Conan he acts scared but
when it really goes down here's what
here's what I think you know that I
would be when the really goes down
and uh here I feel like I could depend
on you to tell me what Lincoln did in a
certain
this is fascinating in 1858 yeah during
the Great skedaddle yeah uh yeah okay
that's fair enough you'd be like hold on
Tim I got this when Roosevelt was in a
similar situation right which Roosevelt
it's important you got to nail that yeah
see this is your department
um I don't know I guess I got over my
skis there a little bit I don't know the
skis I don't know what I would do if I
encountered a real live animal but I
like to think that I'd be physically
very brave and that I'd go down fighting
I'm just still thinking the visual of
you over your skis a little bit
I'll let you know how that goes down
thank you and I are what's your ski
we've never gone uh skiing we've never
hit the slopes we've done we haven't
done most of anything yeah I mean first
of all that's true I'd go skiing with
you anytime and I love skiing I don't
want to go to NOLA to some jazz fest
okay let's go uh what about snowboarding
you go snowboarding I can't do that my
center of gravity is up near my ears but
it's ridiculous I figured it'd be easier
no it's worse snowboarding's harder for
you than skiing
have you have you done it yeah I tried I
I tried snowboarding once and we
actually shot a remote and I ate
Mountain the whole time and what happens
when you snowboard it's the physics of
it is you go down like three times
harder than you would on uh skis and uh
yeah that's yeah yeah I lost like 70 of
my brain capacity that day sorry yeah so
I can't wait you you shot the remote for
the the 2002 Olympics I think sorry I
missed it was it really for the Olympics
you could see it on YouTube oh all my
work is available that's why I've got
the pen so I could write this down
watch Conan on YouTube just kidding
you shouldn't say just kidding out loud
I just wrote JK